[Music]
no no no
the weight bridge is about his last
good hand the supports have told us that
every year to change so that it looks
beautiful shining like a fountain of gold that
bridge that is blamed has been since the
Incas still after no  we get
proud with his account
[Music]
in men in the third pair of walls
I direct the people
and looking at non-arizapana history I
am the construction engineer
we are two males I started on the
right side and on this side where
history does not
this bridge is natural and we don't use
cement nails or any kind of
machine and so we abandoned more by hand we
don't tie up every year
we always do the second weeks of June
the bridge is made up of four hard
two handrails the bridge is 38 meters long
each participant has  what to bring in 40
strokes obligatory thing known
because reach frequency
we do is like this we cut from clipping the
wings in explaining from dry land chang
sing on earth so that it can be  put a
little soft and then we all have
worked with water from the
rope and all of us in the portfolio on the track
make the payment all of it is requested from those
eligible for the license so to
start it is also still to throw
the land so that's it  From the racing
we start that nothing can happen
we are going to do in passing the hard ones to the
front then we just started to
untie the bridge
then we talk when tinplate in
fact it is done it is done you have
left
the rope it has not been easy of dangers
is that people  they are afraid
nervous they would like to be nervous and to be
successful
later we begin to
weave little by little it progresses we find ourselves asymmetrical we
always inaugurate singing dancing
like this we inaugurate at the end when we finish
the bridge I like it a lot right now I am
proud weekend I am happy for you
if they change
and it is being  close to 40 years also my
grandfather would also like that after
my grandfather my father and I even british from
next forever forever
we're going to keep it
's my little boy
my teacher is weaving the story with this
story and it makes us proud bitter
[Music]
sun/mexico series in the new york times
maureen fans
chinampas alcohol hours inclusion arriving i'm going to
leave  from exposing in soft excesses
panticosa mexico the rest line
hezbollah militia from cutting their mouths in the
role of president in chinese companies
moving from artificial 'islands' bild and
avant-garde text only forums the can is
only important your listening pleasure in
and space allocating  selection demonstrated
charlene in the maximum in really rich
I know of pesos progression of the country is
great
the benefits of this crop is that they
are natural they do not bring anything chemical
everything is natural mainly the
organic matter that is extracted from the
canals since it is new  It is good
performance to see local consulting in
studies of attempt to technical
many nutrients for plants that
are vegetables and
China also spends flowers at the beginning it is very
difficult because you have to have day laborers
because the important thing is money
located exactly as hair workers of
management although this end but wenger
has a series of injuries helped at the
team level pharmacies last that follows from
chinampas first previous  integration is
the first single series
- between jorge vallejo in defending the but it
's quiet not even in mexico five laws
with ceremonies mexico the mud walls in the
bastion content is to see and names of
six in mary's respective
restaurants from the river of gold and
guanaceví part  of the
diawara song bulwark of interference work with
with frank hu roldán and organic order
atlistas natural it is possible it is impossible
the dates of factories and neighbors well
have where only hours no more the
soyuz ship and therefore they did not have
work with the farmers propellant
envipaq play where I am because the world
of entities the video with timpani of
progress from the china perf  ormers in
included mind of giles wild turkey wind
and frank feys 'tablets' with chinampas
la pica very different from
foundational password
i exchanges winning by network
the explosion is benin world water
farmers in trying help the peter from
chinampas we believe that the  farmers
to read reviews dancing in the
software and health software of china the
country of the symbol of mexican agriculture
and holder type he was looking for clients or work
xochimilco just be more than the conare
years ago
ah
from the birf here he gets us three times
football
[Music]
protecting is my motto visit spain at like
girls the vice goal that the orientals
walk the best artists of country
latin american cantons are going to
invent from countries like brazil peru
chile and if they depend on basque from countries
colleagues trains in the foreign amount
of instructing and  mustache latin america peanut
local type that the chilean wikileaks of
julian electrica is gay
ramón a saga of yesterday is nobody or fortin
operations of giving  a click invention
in soccer in chile
[Music]
endesa around the world the chilean
jeans version
[Applause]
beats among the people who invent quietly
but the
right-wing sports menino the placement of sacred
bergman uberney marín stylers that are
six of tilín  spectators witness mo
williams as the chalaca between part
chile
[Music]
in this
to
summers and yesterday depression in
leonidas de la selva for being develop
what versions like bicycle war is a
measure is less than river and workshops
and lebanon
[Music]
options
water & shoulders Algerian pre-
existing guantines don't chase him through the south of the country
and cupcakes from the Latin American invention
[Music]
because he begins to learn to handle
the correct thing first
I prefer to show a calculated that they
buy food for the house
[Music]
in other countries he says barriers  illegal
in cuba and the world thinks that a porsche
lamborghini a ctr
here runs a car from the year 30 and baba
is one of the most recognized in the
illegal races he achieves his son is
following in his footsteps and he has it in his
blood
[Music]
in one year the
claw races stopped in Cuba thanks to
what is more or less we have been a
competitive activity all seeing
permission to the  government to the police they
talk about the race in cuba and they don't
mention pete and they don't know anything about these rules
and they have forced him for more than 16 years
unfortunately from 2006
a strong blow that gave me life
but the cancer
will feel bad he said they will take over from the
races  by grandmother and they lived the races
and I felt good if there has been something like that one
that is taken away from you in the Siro church pain
is a method
I am a medical student but I do not
like cars I have two passions it is
treated from the water and being a doctor and
He also runs in the race and follows the
tradition that encompasses
here we have
my car. Right, today the 15 of us
are going. Modification was being made. You have to
franzén 21 to the things that I say
yes to learn to run. You have to  I
learned how to fix a car
[Music]
I always imagined that we would study mechanical engineering and
focus on medicine because I
would like to be a doctor in the future of
priests
[Music]
the two things are related because
medicine has to live and fix
things like it does with  engines and parts
had to wait I tell myself you'll have
bullet time
it will always do well
[Music]
[Applause]